[Musique]
en fait c'est ces actes barbares qui se
commettent sur le corps des femmes sont
souvent des actes qui sont faits un
public en présence des enfants en
présence dé des maris en présence de
toute la communauté avec un objectif non
seulement de détruire la victime mais
également détruire toute toute sa
communauté et aboutit à la destruction
du tissu social et c6 va s'aggraver
surtout lorsque la femme devient
enceinte et qui hélas un enfant issu de
ces viols spectaculaire vous pouvez
imaginer le sort non seulement de la
victime de la femme mais aussi le sort
de cet enfant qui n'est issu du viol
[Musique]
e
elle se présente avec des lésions
diverses c'est les gens peuvent être
dues aux balles réelles peuvent être est
due aux baïonnettes ou aux objets
contendants qui sont introduits au
niveau de l'appareil génital des femmes
apprennent et bien sûr les avoir violées
nous avions eu aussi des cas où les
femmes présentaient des brûlures au
niveau de l'appareil génital
[Musique]
je crois que le fait de reconnaître
cette souffrance apporte un espoir de
voir que finalement le monde ne peut non
seulement envisager des réparations pour
ses victimes mais également des
réparations pour leurs familles qui se
trouvent discriminer isolé et parfois
rejeté par le fait que ces actes
barbares se sont passées dans leur
famille dans leur communauté
donc une réparation est importante pour
permettre à ses pieds et ses victimes
puissent reconstruire leur vie
qu'est ce qu'ils ont commis ces actes
soient reconnus coupables tous tout ce
processus est très important la dernière
chose effectivement c'est espérer que il
y aura de plus en plus des pays qui vont
se mettrent est débout pour tracer cette
ligne rouge contre est d'usagé du viol
comme arme de guerre
c'est ce que nous espérons de ces prix
nobel de la paix